face à cette invasion russe les
occidentaux ont pris des sanctions
inédite contre moscou les conséquences
sont déjà visibles avec notamment la
fermeture de la bourse de moscou et une
chute de la valeur du groupe de plus de
40 % n'en parle société avec alexandre
kateb bonjour vous êtes économiste
fondateurs du site the multipolarité un
report alors est ce que ces sanctions
vont être anglais valady mire poutine et
l'économie russe est donc le pousser à
négocier ce qui est le but à deux
sanctions économiques
ces sanctions sont très durs etc des
sanctions sans précédent notamment
concernant le gel des effectifs de la
banque centrale russe c'est du jamais vu
pour un pays du g20 dont la monnaie est
convertible comme celle de la russie et
donc oui l'impact a été en effet très
massif et immédiat sur les marchés
financiers et sur le système bancaire
russe la banque centrale de russie a dû
monter ses taux d'intérêt à 20% pour
faire face à une crise de liquidité une
évaporation de la liquidité est ce que
cela sera suffisant
ce n'est pas certain puisque on assiste
dans le même temps à une panique à et
des retraits massifs de dents de deux
dépôts notamment les dépôts en dollars
par la population russe donc l'objectif
à court terme a été atteint néanmoins je
crois que ce n'est pas ça qui va faire
dévier vraiment la dîme et les poutine
de son objectif la principale
puisque les conséquences économiques et
financières étaient quelque part
attendues telles qu'elles étaient elles
sont plus sévères que celles qui étaient
vraiment attendu par le régime mais
l'objectif dit les passants fait tout
tout cela est et on n'est plus dans la
dans la sphère vraiment du calcul
économique à ce niveau là
alexandre kateb la question c'est la
déconnexion du système swift donc le
système mondial de transmis sur mon cas
c'est ce qui a pu pousser notamment la
pluie qui slamming d'iran à revenir à la
table des négociations pour son
nucléaire est-ce que c'est plus
compliqué pour la russie à mettre en
place
le système shift oui il a été déconnecté
alors pas pour toutes les banques il
existe des exceptions à l'heure où on
parle et ses exceptions ont été aménagés
pour permettre notamment aux
exportateurs rausis de matières
premières d'être payés notamment
concernant le gaz et le pétrole qui sont
exportés en europe et donc oui ça aura
un impact mais en fait ces sanctions
étaient beaucoup plus anticipé par le
régime et il y a une habitude dans la
gestion de ce type de mesure puisque la
russie a développé depuis 2015 un
système alternatif qui permet de
sécuriser tous les paiements sur le
marché domestique et avec un certain
nombre de pays partenaires dans la chine
donc en fait l'impact de la de
l'exclusion de swift est beaucoup moins
sévère que l'impact de la première
mesure qui est le gel des avoirs de la
banque centrale
merci beaucoup alexandre kateb d'avoir
été en direct sur france 5